alors vous êtes très magazines féminins
finalement vous aimez bien les bûcherons
tout ça oui je vois pas trouvé ici un
petit peu au magazine féminin malgré
tout ouais ouais ce ton bien ah bon oui
j'espère une interview au magazine
féminin
alors est ce que vous êtes prête oui
regardez moi bien vous faites quoi comme
régime en général comme régime
alimentaire oui aucun ah bon je suis
incapable mellal thénia donc elle la
grosse
votre dernier achat de avec votre jules
les croquettes pour le chien
les veaux tient il à la maison et d'or
qu'est-ce qu'il est sympa et c'est tout
beau c'est un bouledogue blanc je le
connais il écrit aussi un peu de
déchet marche isabelle xenos les noces
mais une grande table et nous vous
dormez à gauche ou à droite du lit sur
le chien voilà je dorme et un peu au
milieu ça m'énerve mais un peu au milieu
c'est quoi le petit défaut physique que
vous essayer de cacher chez vous c'est
quelque chose qui se trouve à qui se
voit un petit peu comme le nez au milieu
de la figure de minimum qu'elle d'accord
pourtant j'avais dix petits objets de
pas être votre mais
qu'est ce qui vous fait craquer chez
votre jules abah tout à quoi touba tout
sinon t'es pas avec away we tous ses
yeux son humour son tout dernier achat
coup de coeur s'est conclue questions
complètement vous avez gardé une amie
d'enfance un peu vicieux à key west qui
est brigitte
investigations elle est à lyon on à pau
bah vous dites lui bonjour non avec
l'accent et je crois que nous capte pas
lyon
lançait-elle yverdon-les-bains gay ne me
regarde jamais la télé ah bon pourquoi
pas ce que je fais vous savez dire non
non
c'est que j'ai appris pour dire ouais
ben quoi
c'est une boîte à wayne bonne idée le
valider est ce que vous imaginez une
femme pour diriger la france
monique
bonne idée ouais ouais non ça serait
bien oui si oui n'importe laquelle c'est
toujours mieux que
vous êtes vraiment avec un mec pourquoi
je vois pas ce que des fois je me
demande c'est vrai tout le monde croit
que suis lesbienne ouais et alors tout
jeanne tout le monde crache et
lesbiennes banon je vous plairait quand
même
je crois qu'il ya pas plus et et
roquemaure à bombay c'est ce que disent
tous les biens
non mais j'ai pas du genre les aventures
jamais essayé jamais je n'ai rien n'y a
jamais eu beau c'est dommage pour pas
bon parce qu'il paraît que c'est
agréable à écouter foursquare hommes et
les hommes c'est très bien moi j'étais
lesbienne
ouais ouais alors votre combat le plus
difficile
celui que vous menez ce soir ouais en
fait renoncé oui bah déjà sortir ta
maman des trottoirs
arrête
c'est non on dirait que faire ce métier
en étant une femme c'est pas c'est pas
hyper facile bonnes réponses et vous
mettre toutes les femmes de votre côté
en disant ça vous savez non mais en plus
je veux pas jouer absolument là tu vois
mais c'est vrai que c'est un métier
quand même où c'est assez dur de marier
sa vie quand vous êtes sur cette grande
scène tout petit là j'aimerais qu'un
homme
vous fait quoi en cas de but on
va comme tout le monde je m'énerve eu
qu'à cheval ah non non je crois pas
anna votre coupe faim préféré au le
couscous en général
qu'est ce qui vous donne le sourire le
matin à la gueule de mon chien ça va
faire plaisir à votre mec ça ouais votre
adresse pour ça les concerne le secret
de beauté
en la pénombre j'ai envie dit
la plus grosse honte que vous avez fait
votre mec cdd je ne mangeais pas qu'on
est au resto qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
demande la note on pouvait me donner la
note il fait noir voilà
[Musique]
chérie
il s'appelle aller
alors vous disais quoi en premier votre
horoscope ensuite votre jules est bien
le même on est du même si le chien il
est quoi le chien est verseau comme
giscard d'estaing voilà et non ici les
scorpions comme moi scorpion fou de sexe
le scorpion adore le sexe catherine
barma et scorpions
mais bien entendu c'est le scorpio n'est
pas ça qu'on se trouvait il ya quoi dans
votre sac à main
des trucs de filles habituées là bas non
non cigarettes sexton ah non jamais non
j'ai dû un sudoku tu sais ce que ça
non je sais pas du tout c'est le nouveau
jeu qui fait un ravage et remplacer les
mois
là
vous croyez au string
[Rires]
ces matériaux magazine je crois que
passé trente ans voire et écrous string
c'est comme le père noël il ya un moment
pour revenir à la bouée culotte mais
culotte sympa hein forcément culotte qui
fait des marques un autre info oui ça va
donner la l'âge et la fameuse culotte
qui n'est pas un string qui n'est pas
une culotte parce que j'ai 30 ans et que
j'arrive domaine des strings maintenant
on est obligé qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire mieux que tulle
pour fermer sa gueule
quand il fait les vannes de la note par
exemple lourdaud en feu non mais les
idées mais je sais pas si tu fais ça tu
fais des vannes vraiment tout le temps
toi ou bah ouais moi quand j'avais deux
raisons restons dans les magasins on
vend des habitants voilà ça c'est voilà
il est dans la vie comme à la télé il
est comme ça aussi un van tout le temps
alors des fois faut des fois aux
enterrements cerleau par exemple ça
dépend qui tempère en même temps le
secret d'un couple qui dure
l'humour on va dire ça si bien que c'est
pas moi mais c'est parce que tu détestes
madame de bigard maintenant le monde
parce que tu te mara tu m'as trompé on
s'en fout on rigole
président
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas réglé avec
votre mère rien tout est vrai que nous
avons une relation extrêmement c'est
bien tout à fait c'est bien ah oui ma
mère
l'a principe
la principale qualité d'un mec pour vous
l'intelligence away jamais question de
sexe avec vous un c non mais ça ça ça
vient forcément je veux dire si on est
intelligent mais si on l'est mme sinon
ils nous aiment ce désir ça ça se passe
bien a priori pour vraiment être je veux
dire ah bon non j'ai collé ses deux
roues le monde
le truc que vous n'auriez jamais dû
apprendre sur lui puis vous l'avez
appris et puis voilà qu'il avait connu
des femmes avant mon nombreux supports
partenariat un truc qu'on n'aime pas
qu'on parle et on va pas en parler je
fais confiance pour ce voyage
avait bien
quoi
oui vas-y fais pas c'est quoi mais le
fait qu'ils aient été mariés déjà un oui
non peut pas en parler voilà c'est vrai
je ne savais pas tuer soit qui m'a
cherché mais les gens s'en foutent
pourquoi tu sais ça d'abord parce que je
sais tout je soutiens et hardy c'est la
surprise tu ma part
superbe
dérangerait pas je dirais je veux rester
en bons termes ex mari un des boules ça
me dérangerait pas du tout pourquoi tu
la quittes et
je sais pas parce que non pas si c'est
parce que ça marchait plus point
sexuellement n'importe quoi pourquoi
faut-il toujours que soit sa non non non
non quand même temps globalement comment
combien de temps ensemble pas longtemps
deux ans
mais c'est pas grave arrêtez ça fait de
la peine quand même c'est pareil viens à
ma dernière question évidemment une
question très très important
est ce que vous faites l'amour le matin
ou le soir
il prend son air le matin ou le soir oui
l'après midi voilà non c'est vrai que je
trouve que c'est sympa l'après midi
pourquoi le chef lui en fait ce que
d'avoir ta part parce que tu sais pas
faire
pourquoi à bonne école
pour tous passeront pc l'année on a
changé la date
limite en menant au sort depuis
tellement c'est trop mignon en riant tu
vois la gueule des gosses
c'est débrouille on appelait ça des
moyens fait pas les scolariser son passé
[Rires]
toujours en noir le secret de la voilà
m
weston et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu